quick update about the scam riddled
Trump University uh Trump University is
this weekend seminar to get you to do a
longer seminar to get you to pay up to
thirty-five thousand dollars for
coaching which will make you really
really wealthy that's Trump University a
bunch of lawsuits 10,000 students uh
enrolled in the school they paid between
fifteen hundred and thirty-five thousand
dollars a number of lawsuits were
started saying this entire thing was a
scam we were sold a bill of goods and we
never got what we were promised
president-elect Donald vowed to fight
the lawsuits against Trump University he
previously tweeted I will never settle
because I did nothing wrong here is a
prior tweet from Donald Trump Trump
University has a ninety-eight percent
approval rating I could have settled but
won't out of principle Trump once
explained to an Arkansas crowd I don't
settle lawsuits probably should have
settled it but I just can't do that
mentally I can't do it I'd rather spend
a lot of money and fight it well it
turns out that president-elect Donald
has agreed to settle for 25 million
dollars with the students that allege
that the Trump University institution
engaged in fraud as part of the
agreement Trump does not have to admit
fault but by Trump's own claim Pat he
doesn't settle when he's in the right
even put out a more recent tweet
bragging about how how he settled the
case for far less than what the people
were demanding which you'd have to
expect right this actually this case was
supposed to be broadcast on television
some kind of upset that it got settled
and won't be going any further yet that
would be a fantastic but that'll be the
most that would have been the most
compelling case to watch since the
George Zimmerman trial which I watched
basically from gavel-to-gavel do you
understand what's going on the incoming
president is paying people millions of
dollars tens of millions of dollars
after thousands of people sued him for
defrauding them and scamming them
unknown scammer is being entrusted to
help people improve their financial
situations which doesn't seem like he's
going to do to be the guy who has the
nuclear codes at his disposal this is
insanity and by the way when it comes to
settling lawsuits a former trump
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway said
that Bill Clinton said
on one of his rape accusations was
tantamount to an admission of guilt
someone should ask her what Trump
settlement in this case is tantamount to
although we know what they would say
they would say no the president-elect is
too busy for this and because he's so
wealthy he realized it just made sense
to settle this thing and get it off the
books he didn't admit admit any guilt
because it's time to move on and be
President of the United States the fact
that he settled this case by the way
suggests that his apartment rental
policies were racist because he also
settled that racism lawsuit
discrimination lawsuit against them
fascinating huh make America great again
it's gonna be great really soon I
predict within days of january twentieth
America will be really really great
again coming up next our investigation
into the movement known as the alt right